[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting We are continuing sex
Timbers
that's when it falls what does a tree
symbolize
a large penis it's a phallus yes
okay it's a phallus of some sort making
sure we're on the same page
um last week was great this week is
going to be great we got another guest
to just just to Enlighten us to keep us
in on proper information Dr Emily
nagoski so excited about this is a sex
educator speaker and award-winning
author of The New York Times
best-selling book come as you are and it
comes to our workbook and co-author with
her sister Amelia of the New York Times
bestseller burn out the secret to
unlocking the stress cycle Dr n
is director of Wellness education at
Smith college where she teaches a course
on women's sexuality she combines sex
education and stress education to teach
women to live with confidence and Joy
inside their bodies
uh we you know we've actually already
had this conversation that you're about
to listen to I gotta say I learned a lot
yeah uh she instructed us to call her
Emily that's why we call her Emily
although she is a doctor and as you will
see a very well qualified one at that uh
continuing to Enlighten these uh these
boys that are just hungry to learn about
sex if you don't want to hear
um specific and explicit talk about sex
um don't listen to this episode that's
your warning
midterm elections are coming up on
November 8th and across the U.S people
are going to be voting on some pretty
crucial spots in Congress Governors and
special elections and we want you to
vote too yes so vote like a beast is
here to help you go to vote
likeabeast.com you can check your voting
status there you can register if you
need to and you can stay informed on
midterm elections we're also selling
some stickers over at vote
likeabeast.com and 100 of our profits go
directly to our partners over at
vote.org this is a website that we
created to help you so be your mythical
best by supporting a great non-profit
that helps all Americans exercise their
right to vote go to vote likeabeast.com
all right notice that you are and I I
listened to the uh will lack of sleep
kill you by the way yes it will um and
you had a conversation about Link's
glasses and I'm wearing very similar
glasses and I thought oh good I'm not
gonna have to explain about your glasses
and now you're not wearing those glasses
ah do you have them
oh now you want me to wear the glass
well I mean of course I have the glass I
feel like I feel like making guests feel
at home you know we don't always have
guests it's just when we want to talk
about something uh where we want an
expert involved
this even a sex bird involved uh I want
them to feel welcome
so I wear mine because uh I'm I get
migraines and the light for my screen is
a trigger and this filters out the blue
light that activates it so are yours
also for medical reasons or you just
want to look like yeah I can't wait for
this answer
um you're wearing those for medical
reasons
uh yeah because I mean being being
feeling good is medical right these make
you feel good they make me feel good I'm
glad that we are
we're cohorts now
yeah Emily we can share this look at
that we're seeing the world in an orange
and you look cool I don't care about I
don't care about medical reasons you can
just do it for the cooler can I just say
that now that this has happened I feel
very left out like no you're damn right
and you are left out hold on one second
I'll be right back
this is
I feel like he's gonna come back in year
2000 New Year's Eve glasses I'm just mad
that like he was giving me nothing but
about my glasses which I don't care
about that that didn't make me mad
that's his problem
but now
because he respects you so much Emily I
guess or wants to impress you he's
totally switched sides like I know he's
going to come back with something
yep if nothing else happens I have made
your life easier
yeah oh my gosh
those are prop glasses like you're not
gonna wear those out in the room
I've been meaning to I didn't know it
was gonna happen this soon but um
the glass I kind of feel like I've been
forced into this okay so you're making
fun of me and Emily no we're doing this
sincerely this is she has migraines she
has migraines and I have I'm cool you
never know when my you're not might
start you're neither you never know when
migraines might start I mean you're
nothing to it things start happening
when you know what I think we are not
the same uh we're all basically the same
age Let's Talk About Sex yeah I am I was
born in 77 you're a 77 77 78 baby it's
supposed to be about sex things start
happening you get migraines I'm gonna
find a way to make this relevant to
sexuality I'm getting so sexually
frustrated right now like I feel blue
balls are real I feel very sexy and you
know what that let's talk about that a
little bit because about blue balls uh
well we can talk about blue balls oh we
can talk about are blue balls real
because I was about to ask you a
question before we care about you and
your glasses uh and that is how you feel
about the way that you look
can have an impact on your what happens
in the the bedroom so to speak right oh
yeah body image and stress are the top
two things that hit the brakes which I'm
sure we'll talk about the Dual control
model but body image and stress top two
trauma not far behind okay so yeah but
to get the blue balls out of the way
because everything you just mentioned is
where we're going in this in this
podcast
are blue balls really a thing because
I or is it just something that sexually
frustrated people with balls dangle over
others to to to get what they want I
actually don't know
I think I'll be tell me what you mean by
blue balls because people mean different
things
like I am Avatar my body is ready like
uh like if if things continued another
let's say
you know five or ten minutes
then I could ejaculate or one let's say
let's not make this about me one could
ejaculate yeah one with balls could
ejaculate and then so like physically
there's a pain of the all the soldiers
lining up to go into
battle Yeah but but yet at the last time
you know what uh we're calling off back
to the barracks it's just a war game
back to the balls Barracks you know
you're not you're not you're not coming
out to the war games
and it hurts no it is working and there
is a there the balls don't actually turn
blue
but they hurt they it there's a physical
discomfort that can come with
experiencing a really high level of
arousal and then having that stop
especially if it stops suddenly
yeah and there is nothing dangerous
about it nobody has ever died or even
suffered an injury as a result of yeah
okay
um and the problem arises when someone
takes the discomfort of a sudden
Interruption of a high-level arousal as
entitlement to orgasm like you have to
because I don't feel I I need it you
don't need it nothing bad is going to
happen to you if you if you really need
to keep going go be by yourself for a
couple of minutes and get the job done
if you want to yeah um and okay mostly
what you're experiencing is sexual
frustration which no one has ever
suffered injury due to sexual
frustration right okay good to hear so
don't don't dangle the blue balls as as
as some sort of ultimate and don't worry
that next time you get blue balls that
you might die
yeah literally nothing bad will happen
to you except that your partner who is
like you know what I'm not ready to go
any further you can be like okay
okay we can stop now and they'll have
mad respect for you
um let's talk can we talk about the
books
now I
come as you are I this is an amazing
book I know it's been out for like seven
years the fact that I mean it's a
testimony to how powerful this book is
as a resource to people I love it this
is our recommendation today come as you
are
um
Emily's book one of many what's the name
of your new book by the way the stress
one burnout burnout yeah we're gonna
shout out that one too but shout out to
burnout so my my daughter Lily
um you know when she went off to college
last year a mentor of hers gave her this
book and I saw it around because I
noticed the cover like the cut this is
one this is a brilliant cover I mean you
know it's it's uh eye-catching pink and
then there's a open zipper that is very
vulvic
I mean if I don't know if that's what
you were going for but I'm pretty sure
it was I don't know what you're talking
about I think it's just a purse that's
right that thing's got to be on the
Shelf in Barnes and Noble you can't be
just having a vulva out there this is an
amazing this is one of the best book
covers I have ever seen but I gotta be
honest there's a dark side to it like
yeah I get a little
it's a little visceral when you think
about like putting your wiener in a in
in some um something that could zip
something that can zip up like you get a
little something about them during my
time during my teenage years there was
very few things that I wouldn't place my
wiener in
you know uh the the ways this whole
Reddit communities the ways that you the
ways that you could find a masturbate as
a teenager was just I feel like I could
write a book about that I mean Zippity
Doo Dah Zippity oh it probably wouldn't
sell as well as yours you know I have a
friend don't you have been masturbating
since before he since he was like a
little kid
um and the way he masturbated was to lie
in his stomach and hump his mattress and
have an orgasm and just feel like done I
lost my virginity to a mattress to my
bed actually I'll tell you about that in
a second go ahead no you just told her
um
and then one day when he was about 13 he
did his usual humping the mattress feels
really good and all this stuff
came out of his penis and he panicked he
was sure he had broken something so he
ran to his mom and was like this oh I
don't know what happened but I'm really
worried that some like there's a disease
or and his mother was totally cool about
it she was like this is just a normal
part of what happens let's go run the
laundry and you're gonna be just fine
this is probably gonna keep happening
that's one of my favorite stories of
like an early masturbation experience
that didn't reinforce shame but was just
like yeah that's normal that happens
because it could have gone another way
well it did with us you know we come I
have a random my mom and told her
anything about my jizz right well we
come from a conservative Evangelical
Christian background uh that you know it
gives you a certain
um set of beliefs about sex that then
you have to deconstruct as you as you go
grow older uh but yeah the first time I
masturbated I definitely thought I broke
my
I was not about to tell my mom about it
but then you were you were pleasantly
surprised that it wasn't powder you did
the discovery last year the discovery of
the having sex with the bed which if
you're listening and you want and you
need any tips I will say that you just
find something uh like a shoe uh and
usually Two Shoes the thing about shoes
and just roll with me here is that the
you know a shoe has like a gradation
like if you get like a Converse All-Star
if you take the mattress and the box
spring right so you've got the mattress
and the box spring you can put the shoes
in and the further you wedge the shoes
in it changes the size of the opening
between your mattress and your your uh
box springs and that's the thing that
you're screwing by the way is that
opening and you just dial it in so
you're penetrating the gap between the
mattress and the bedspread yeah yeah so
it's like a sideways vagina and then I
hope you're using a lot of lube well
here's the thing I don't I definitely
don't recommend this uh because there
was it I mean you know I was like a 15
year old kid that I mean what happens
when you flip your mattress my hands
could have been made of sandpaper and it
wouldn't have stopped it would have
stopped me I mean as a 13 year old boy I
was religiously flipping my mattress
every month rotate oh there's a flip
there's a towel there's a flip there's a
towel in there then there's a flip and
Rotator there's a towel in there because
you don't want you don't find that
situation you know I mean don't use your
again the friction just feels like it's
going to be really high oh I'm sure it
was it was probably not healthy uh but
nothing could stop me nothing could stop
me you like pleasure spiked with pain
and music is your airplane
um one of my favorite things about your
book which we would actually like to do
right now if you don't mind is we would
like to actually take the sexual
temperament quiz okay on page 54. I mean
there's only 10 questions but before we
could take it along with us well we can
kind of we'll walk through our answers
that way you can get to know us oh yeah
yeah as you're listening I thought we
could read all the questions give our
answers then Emily you kind of know
where we stand then we can kind of talk
that out and then talk about people who
are maybe if we're the same different
than us or different than the two of us
even if we're different
but give us some context
um
for the sexual temperament questionnaire
right so this is a little Cosmo quiz
version of the actual scientific
instrument that researchers use to
assess uh what's known as the Dual
control model of sexual response okay so
the idea here is that humans like all
mammals have a mechanism in their brain
that controls sexual response and it's a
dual control mechanism which means it
has two parts and the first part is a
sexual accelerator that a lot of us are
familiar with it notices all the sex
related information in the environment
that's everything that you see hear
smell touch taste or crucially
everything you think believe or imagine
that your brain codes as related to sex
it takes all the information in and it
sends the turn on Signal that many of us
are familiar with
it's working at a low level right now
here we are talking about sex this is
just a tiny little bit of sex related
information so you're getting just a
little tiny bit of activation of the
accelerator at a subconscious level
fortunately at the same time you have
the second mechanism the brakes okay
noticing all the good reasons not to be
turned on right now that's everything
that you see here smell touch taste fake
believe or imagine that your brain codes
as a Potential Threat and it sends the
turn off signal both of them are
functioning all the time so your level
of arousal at any given moment is a
balance of how much the ons are turned
on and how much the offs are turned off
oh okay and people have different
sensitivities of these mechanisms most
of us are piled up in the middle we're
just medium in the sensitivity of our
accelerator and our brakes some people
have a really sensitive accelerator
which if you drive a car that's got a
really sensitive accelerator that's
gonna do a lot of Jerkins
exactly High sensitivity uh yeah and if
you have a really low sensitivity
accelerator like it takes a lot more gas
and a lot more time to get you where you
want to go and some people have a really
sensitive break these are actually the
folks who are the most prone to sexual
dysfunction because it turns out the
best predictor of sexual difficulties is
not not enough stimulation to the
accelerator it's too much stimulation to
the brakes oh
so as we go so I see this there's a this
is a very helpful way to think about it
yeah because it it because you know and
you talk about this
as well just the the the misnomer of sex
drive well let's get back to that I
don't want to talk about it yet I want
to do the test first if you ever want to
talk about that but so and then some
people have a really low sensitivity of
breaks uh which even if you're driving a
car that just has like a regular level
of accelerator sensitivity if your
brakes are not responsive enough
some not so great things can happen
right okay so for us but most of us are
in the middle I see this let's find out
there's an Inhibitors page five
questions and so we're supposed to add
up our numbers here and then on the
other page there's an exciter's five
questions so let's just go through them
and then we can
kind of Flesh this out okay okay
um on a scale of zero to four zero
meaning not like you at all and four
exactly like you
uh answer this sometimes I have so many
worries that I am unable to get aroused
sometimes I have so many worries I'm
unable to get aroused zero not at all
for exactly like me this is this is
complex
because
okay so as a as someone who thinks about
these things in the context of a
21-year marriage
I think about the fact that stress often
um
makes me want to go and
okay but not necessarily have an
encounter with my wife because that can
sometimes be like well yeah I got I got
in that scenario I've really got to
think about her and I've got to make it
an enjoyable experience for her and that
can seem like work sometimes when you're
already stressed out right you've
already just told me something about the
sensitivity of your accelerator about 10
to 20 percent of people find that when
their stress is increased their interest
in sex is increased and it will not
necessarily be for partnered sex or for
their relationship with their long-term
partner but it will increase their
interest in sexual release in porn or in
a higher risk kind of sexual behavior
um so my guess already is that you're
going to score on the higher end of the
sexual excitation scale which is the
accelerator yeah so because I relate to
that but then I you know also when when
I get when I I'm in a stressful Zone
like oh this this week or these couple
of weeks have really piled up I realize
that I haven't thought about
having sex
so definitely in high stress times I'm
like oh yeah it's it's now I'll call
this a sex dry spell the old dry spell
but neither one of those is this this is
like arousal I have I have so many
worries that I'm unable to get aroused I
think that I can always I mean when I'm
in go mode
it's like I can usually compartmentalize
and overcome it it's just a question of
do I want to comment at all but once
I've once I've engaged in being there
um I don't get two in my head so I'm
gonna I'm gonna put a one two next one
unless things are quote just right it is
difficult for me to become sexually
aroused zero
um
yeah I I'm a very meticulous person and
a house could be burning down I yeah I'm
not gonna I I mean you think someone
could be like pummeling yourself
actively a boxer could be in your face
it could be an intruder taking my
television and be like hold on now
priorities man yeah I'm gonna put them
some people who score
four on this are there people who like a
stray piece of grit on the sheets a
stray fingernail a stray thought a stray
sound in the hallway can just shut
everything right down those are the
people who are forced for me I'm like
if the dogs are still in the bed that's
their problem
[Laughter]
you know what that is their problem I am
not going to live in a world where my
dogs dictate if I'm able to get Nookie
or not and Christy and I have had your
dogs Barbara knows they know something's
up Barbara knows the Mommy and Daddy are
doing
special time and that's when she just
goes into her her house she like just
she's like kind of like okay and it goes
in there and then just kind of lays down
Jade kind of looks away
and I'll I'll pick him up and put them
on we have eye contact is a problem I'll
put the I'll put the dogs on the couch
and then so they can watch and then uh
if they want to I do not care
exhibitionist that's my thing is that
like
and
um yeah Christy's fine with that too but
if like the dog's trying to like crawl
up in there and like get in your get in
somebody's face what's going on it's
like Jasmine we have a dog like that she
wants to participate right so you got to
set her outside you just gotta close the
door yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
participate yeah that's a that's a lot
all right so it just wants to be like
right up in there like hi everybody yeah
she sees love happening yeah
yeah my dogs do they do tend to know
that something's up they're like they do
face away
I think that I don't know they can see
and smell a lot of things we can't right
I think the smell has a lot to do with
it if I'm uncertain how my partner feels
about me it's harder for me to get
aroused okay I can I'm I'm gonna move up
this one like if I know
if I'm uncertain it's like if something
is Christy mad at me or what have I have
I done something yeah I mean that's
gonna
you know
you want you this is a I want I want I
want this to be like us both to be at
the party you know what I'm saying well
I have this thing that happened and I
get concerned about that Emily help me
understand that I'm gonna put a three
for that I'm gonna put a one for this
because sometimes
uh
uh Jesse first of all we have a what I
call a high frequency low uh amplitude
conflict
situation in our marriage right so
there's you fight a lot but it's never
really we don't we don't blow out we
don't build up the resentment and then
it blows out it's just like we're
constantly kind of like in love and also
arguing with each other it's a beautiful
thing it's lasted for 21 years yeah and
we're not like that
um and sometimes when she gets mad at me
it turns me on I don't know what it is
but like she'll like she's like she
she's got an opinion about something and
she's really getting into it and then
like I'm all like we're having an
argument about something then I'm just
like oh I had like just something just
something happens and I'm kind of turned
on I don't know what it is not liking it
like we don't do like the Dom stuff
where like we don't we haven't
experimented with that I'm not saying I
wouldn't we just haven't done that yet
so it's not like oh you know dominate me
but it's more a little again a little
feisty that's a little sexy right now
and then she starts laughing and then it
usually diffuses the situation that's
not why I'm doing it it's just my
natural response am I am I okay Emily
you are you're normal you're fine there
could be a couple of different
explanations for why it happens and I
think a big part of it is the fact that
your anger is not escalating to a high
level you're just a little irritated or
annoyed and then she is irritated and
annoyed in response and first of all
that's a connection that's an emotional
connection you haven't escalated to a
place where you're no longer connected
John gottman's research shows that when
people's heart rates get above 100 beats
per minute they lose their ability to
listen to each other but you're not
allowing the stress levels in your body
to escalate to that point you're just
getting a higher level of activation
than usual
together and
am I wrong in thinking that you enjoy
your wife as a person
you're not wrong huh so like here she is
being her full personhood you are
connected together at a high level of
intensity that is not disconnecting you
yeah it makes sense to me that that
would be arousing and that's one of the
reasons I fell in love with her too like
you know when we were dating was that
she just got she was passionate about
stuff and I was like damn I like that so
I think I'm just continuing to be
attracted to her in that way yeah yeah
there's more about connection than it is
about the conflict to me is like let's
the resolution is what brings on the
Harney for us it's like making up
yes is that very fun yeah
so that's very much about attachment so
the biology of Love is human attachment
originates in the fact that our infants
are
entirely dependent on their adult
caregivers if you leave them by the side
of the road they will just die of
exposure if they're not eaten by a bear
first human babies are ridiculous
they're heavy they make a lot of noises
they smell weird right there we care to
admit
when somebody hands you a baby and it's
like this one's yours keep it alive no
matter how like frustrated and resentful
you feel there is nothing on Earth that
will stop you from showing up to help
that baby when that baby needs you
that's attachment uh and around
adolescence that infant caregiver system
gets co-opted into peer-to-peer
relationships
um now when you're an infant your life
literally depends on your adult
caregiver coming back when you need them
when you're an adult that's not
literally the case but your body doesn't
know that so when there is a threat to
your attachment object a threat to this
attachment connection one of the
strategies adults have to reconnect when
there's a threat to the attachment is
sex so that's why make up sex and even
break up sex can be so intense is it's
fueled by this like desperate oh my God
I need to fix this attachment or else I
could die
um well that's why so I gave that a
three I gave it a one you gave it a one
okay if I am worried about taking too
long to become aroused or to orgasm this
can interfere with my arousal
um
uh if I'm worried about taking too long
to become aroused or orgasm
I feel like I'm watching two guys
grapple with the question that women
would be like oh yeah definitely
yeah well the interesting thing you know
and when you have a penis uh obviously
obviously there there are there there's
lots of signals that are happening uh
you know uh with a vulva and vagina and
everything down there uh but there can
be this like am I a full
um full masked half-mast
because there's such an obvious like
you're either on or you're off
uh I do think that there could be times
like oh it's not happening as fast as I
expected this to happen or oh oh am I
about to
I'm I'm trying I'm trying to go longer
tonight I'm really trying to go for it
tonight to show how great of a lover I
am and oh gosh I'm about to lose my
erection you know like yeah that those
kind of things can get into your head at
times so I would I think I might go with
a good two on this one I'm gonna give it
a one
um sometimes I feel so shy or
self-conscious during sex that I cannot
become fully aroused I'm gonna put a
zero for that yeah that doesn't happen
for me okay so that that's all we have
again the women are all like really
yeah
okay so yeah I'm just not four there
oh you guys and both of those are for
cultural reasons there's nothing innate
in being born in an it's a girl kind of
body that makes a person self-conscious
about their body or feel shy about
sexuality that's entirely cultural it's
because we're trained from birth to hate
our bodies and feel ashamed of our
genitals
I know right
let's move over to exciters I I got a
total of six there you got a total of
four for inhibitors
did I win same scale zero to four I'm
very I'm very competitive I was gonna
say I was like dang it because I I took
the test too just to see like the female
perspective and I was like dang that's
what they got I have uh a 12 for mine
okay okay so we'll come back so you know
what you win unless this is Golf and I
win I win and Jenna wins if it's
traditional Sports Jenna wins all right
keep taking it Somebody's gotta win on
the inside hero some World seeing a
partner doing something that shows their
talent or intelligence or watching them
interacting well with others can make me
very sexually aroused zero not like me
for exactly like me oh this is a big one
for me man I think somebody can become
uh
uh somebody can become much more
attractive when they are demonstrating
their intelligence you're talking you're
talking about Hot for Teacher uh yeah
the top for Teacher uh-huh and all
Dynamic someone uh you know maybe that's
a different Dynamic well likewise
someone can become very unattractive
um when there's nothing there except the
the external yeah Mr Bryant was a great
physics teacher but there were other
things that and I liked his sense of
humor but there were just things about
him that uh didn't make me horny well it
you know I think it's the kind of thing
that's sorry to bring you into this Mr
Brian you're scrolling through Instagram
and you see uh you know there it's not
uncommon it's not uncommon to see a
beautiful woman uh on Instagram oh well
on your for you page uh yeah and I you
know yeah and I think the algorithm
knows that I like beautiful women
uh but then when you go to the profile
and see that it seems that the the uh
the algorithm knows what you think a
beautiful woman the extent of this
account is beautiful woman at that point
it's like
I'm not as attracted to this person at
this point yeah but if this person was
like couldn't you have a video of you
solving some physics equations
yeah Mr Bryant was a physics teacher I
don't know if I said that but yes okay
exuding Talent OR intelligence or
interacting well with others like uh I'm
gonna I'm gonna put a three
what'd you put I put it for okay when I
think about someone I find sexual what'd
you put Jenna we'll go we'll go one by
one this time oh uh I I put a three yeah
intelligence and and passionate is yeah
I like when I think about someone I find
sexually attractive or fantasize about
sex I easily become sexually aroused oh
yeah four yeah I mean if I'm gonna what
what else if I'm gonna why would I be
fantasizing
what do I expect is going to happen I
mean what what else could happen if you
help us understand someone Emily who
might score that low
did you score at Logan uh I I did not
score low I I've actually I'm a high
accelerator I'm one of the don't skip
ahead I'm just saying but what number I
got I put a three all right three you
got a Tesla Model S up in there Emily
what what were you gonna say
so people with low sensitivity
accelerators are less likely to
fantasize in the first place and when
they do fantasize it's more a
traditional experience of daydreaming
where they're just imagining that
something could happen without it
necessarily being a really visceral
experience
I don't see I don't know that I've ever
sat around and just had a fantasy
what do you mean
are you saying that like you've had like
a fantasy for the sake of like the
utility to be able to masturbate and you
don't consider that a fantasy because
obviously you've done that like when
you're walking down the street or you're
sitting in heavy traffic you're
daydreaming letting your mind wander and
it goes to like sexual things that could
happen or couldn't happen that's good
yeah okay well I'll change mine too
quite a bit Yeah but yeah yeah that
makes sense
if it is possible someone might see or
hear us having sex it is more difficult
for me to get aroused watch the numbers
on this one it's reverse scored reverse
scored four means not like me at all
zero is exactly like me
so the scale goes down the more you
relate to this if if it is possible
someone might see or hear us having sex
it's more difficult to get aroused I not
that's not like me at all I mean we were
in the car going at it and a hiker walks
by
and then I was like just just get down
how can I hide we were both down but
like uh right on the outside of the
window but like you know there's the the
sun had gone down and I think you the
hiker would probably see a reflection of
themselves steamy
potentially yeah
it was early on though in the in the
festivities but then another hiker walks
by and another hiker it was a freaking
Cavalcade of hikers like they were in
like a chain well you should never hike
alone really
the more hikers that came by the more I
was kind of into it especially when it's
dark out what are these I don't think
they were hikers I think they might have
been
um it might have been scavengers uh
hookup spot oh wait oh yeah yeah it's a
it's a it was dusk and they were they
were wearing hiking attire I can gear
okay they had spent a day on the
mountain maybe that's their Kink I don't
know uh so for me but your experience
that's not like me at all because I do
not it that does not make it more
difficult for me to get aroused whereas
another person in that situation like
the first hacker goes by and you're like
and the second person goes by and you're
like oh no we're done
yeah
yeah I put a three on this one uh I I
downgraded from a four uh you know we
talked on a previous podcast about how
sometimes you'll be staying in one of
those
um hotels and uh I don't know what part
of the conversation on the previous
podcast was edited out so I don't know
what I know I don't listen back to it
but all I was saying was that you're in
a high-rise hotel and you realize that
you've left the window open
and then like my disposition is just
like
okay
I there's a little bit of an
exhibitionist in me right
um and then recently speaking of hiking
we're entertainers Jesse and I went on a
hike and
it was a you know we're it's Los Angeles
so you you can't get a loan on a hiking
trail but there was like off no banks on
this particular uh trail and I was like
Hey like uh what do you think about
taking a little offshoot finding a big
rock or something and you know having a
little fun and she was like that okay
that sounds fun uh but we did not
realize that we had gotten ourselves in
a situation now first of all also I'm
six seven she's five three you do math
on that
and uh what would that be subtraction uh
yeah yeah what's your okay we were both
standing up
oh on like a Creek Bank
and that was when we realized that the
main trail looped back around and was
like 20 feet from us and like saw like
three heads like walking by and at that
point I would say that
the reason I immediately was like oh I
mean she was also like that it was just
I just don't want to be you know what if
I get recognized man you know I don't
it's just I don't want that to be the
memory that someone has of me so that's
why I'm not putting a four because you
don't want to educate like a family of
yeah somebody calls from the trail here
exactly yeah that's the situation that
I'm not interested in but if you're
staying in a hotel that's got thin walls
and you know that the people can hear
you like my disposition is to get louder
and like put on a show for the people in
the Next Room not in an impositional way
but just like don't let that be the
reason that you get quiet
you know what I'm saying so I'm gonna go
with the three all right
um I do want to point out that there are
a lot of people for whom the idea of
potentially being caught or seen is
arousing but the reality of being in a
situation where they could be caught or
seen is not it just shuts everything
down and that's totally normal it's
because the context of actually being in
a situation where you could be seen and
potentially not safe is different from
the fantasy world where you can control
the idea that you actually are totally
safe the whole time yeah that's what you
get to happen in Asia all right so I'm
going to lower mine from a four to a
three for that reason Jenna what did you
put well we have we have slightly
different editions of the book so my my
quiz is a little different than than
yours so I don't have that question but
I'd
as someone who has done those things and
also been caught in those situations uh
I I'd say I'd say probably like like a
three like if you don't if I if I don't
get caught it's really fun it was really
fun okay yeah I really like it but yeah
getting getting caught I'm like crap
this is this is very embarrassing and
mortified the quiz changed from addition
to Edition because people requested that
I put in one that was more inclusive of
people of every gender and hormone
combination
therapist in particular wanted me to
make it so that anybody in a couple
could take the same quiz gotcha is that
the one that's why they're different
we've got the new one
yes
um here's a straightforward one two more
to go particular scents are very
arousing to me for exactly like you
one not at all you're going to Bed Bath
and Body Works and you just like you got
another place you gotta what
Bed Bath and Beyond or Bath and Body
Works let me use the Bed Bath and Body
Works which first of all great collab
idea
because I think that would work I think
there's a the Venn diagram of is just a
circle there I'm saying this is not much
like me I I don't I don't really think
about I mean we've said on the show that
stink makes maybe think more about body
smell how about I say yeah dude I put a
four because oh I was talking about
candles
no man the smell of this I mean let's
just you know my biggest disappointment
in goop um
uh and I have many
is uh
is the fact that the the candle that's
supposed to smell like a vagina doesn't
smell like a vagina
uh it's just again what does it smell
like it just smells like a good candle
right like I don't feel like there was
much effort we had one on the show and
you know I haven't I'm not saying I've
smelled a lot of vagina it was candle
fragrant there was no there wasn't any
like human
sent in that I could detect I'm sure no
two vaginas smell the same but there's a
general there's a there's a general sort
of sort of undertone yeah right that I
think is I mean that's the best smell in
the world and when we talk about stink
make me horny that's what what some
people you know there's there's this
like subversion of this is an
interesting scent unlike any other scent
whether it's a vagina or another scent
it's like oh this is provocative versus
I would go I would go a step further and
say that I'm still going to put mine you
know I regret the fact that in modern
society we've become so
you know cleanliness obsessed because
like the whole that whole idea of like
somebody stinking a little bit and it
making you horny is like that feels like
that was the norm for most of human
history until we started deciding that
we had to like always smell of it's
completely clean right aren't we just
washing all our pheromones off and that
was happening these days
humans don't have pheromones oh snap
that's why we bring people who know what
they're talking about on this part well
actually we don't very often but let me
say that there is no evidence yet that
we have pheromones so so I can't say yes
it's because of pheromones do smell
different they're like tiny chemicals
that communicate information about sex
okay by which I mean like
which one you are uh and like for a
whole lot of other animals the
vomaronasal gland is actively
functioning in uh perceiving pheromones
but there's no evidence that humans
actually we have a vomaronasal gland but
there's no evidence that we're excreting
pheromones for it to detect what we can
smell when like you know you smell
t-shirts and you can tell which one is
your spouse correct what we're smelling
is a combination of things but in
particular MHC which is a factor in your
immune system
that says something about how
similar to you this person's immune
system is
interesting whoa in the more similar the
more attracted the opposite because the
more similar the more likely you are
related
oh wow because we we talked we did the
thing on the show a while back and we
did very a very tame version of it but
it was based on that study which I'm
sure you're familiar with
which is where they gave people the
shirts to smell and then yours what
you've found attractive through smell
lined up what you found attractive
physically
um or what I'm sure I'm giving a bad
interpretation of it basically you could
anticipate who you would be everybody
gives a bad interpretation you could
anticipate who you're going to be
attracted to reliably by just smelling
the the shirts
maybe that it wasn't panties in this
particular I don't know of a study that
does that does underwear I think that
would be a really interesting experiment
but I don't know of one there we go yes
let's see if we can get better Body
Works to sign up for that experience I
mean they're certain funded by Beth Bed
Bath and Body Works people who put a
four would be lined up around the block
so what number did you put I put a two
uh I put it for
Jenna and let me say this is one of the
single best predictors of having a quite
a sensitive accelerator
yeah I'm I'm a four I've smell is a big
yeah he who smelt it dealt it I think
about sex a lot when I am bored this is
the final one Make It Count zero not at
all for exactly like me when I'm bored
when I'm bored I definitely think about
sex more when I'm bored than when I'm
not I'll say three a lot like me I'm
gonna put a four just because I feel
like this is my
has been since I went through puberty
it's my default like if I get bored it's
the first thing that my my mind goes to
Jenna what'd you put let's add these up
uh I'm a I'm a somewhat I was I yeah I
think I'm that that one isn't in my quiz
either but yeah I think I'm I I if I'm
bored I usually make up whole entire
romantic scenarios like the perfect date
someone would take me on like a little
romance of it and I know I never really
get to the the just the sex part I guess
all right so my let's go through totals
so on on this side of Exciter I got a
14. right I got a 19.
and Jenna you're up there
oh yeah I'm an 18. I'm like oh you're
damn you're an 18. okay so to have
so I'm just to say these one more time
Emily and then maybe you can like lump
us into categories or or just tell us
how to interpret this make just gross
generalizations about all of us I'm six
foot I'm 6 14.
right I am 419 and Jenna you are 12 18.
well these are all that's my wife's
birthday
so we're so what what are you going to
do with that data so you look up in the
in the uh oh graph like there's this
there's an answer sheet that tells you
like where your score lies in terms of
low medium high
for each of the two scales
yeah because one of the important things
is the two do not co-vary like just
because your accelerator sensitive
doesn't mean your break is sensitive or
insensitive okay so
um in the inhibitor side with the brakes
zero to six is low so both of us are low
medium is 7 to 13 and high is 14 to 20.
so yeah so I'm on I'm on the medium Yeah
medium okay so should we just give us a
little bit about what is it if you're on
the low side what does that mean
if you're in
low income when you have a low
sensitivity break what that indicates
mostly it means that uh your accelerator
regardless of how sensitive it is is
gonna have an easy time overpowering
your brakes and so you'll be motivated
to do things and all the good reasons
not to be turned on right now your
brain's not particularly convinced that
those are good reasons so but if you see
like a road closed sign you just drive
through it
you're like there's nobody coming it's
fine to use a crude analogy and then
yeah and then with the middle the
combination of like a middle level
accelerator plus a heist or a middle
level break in a high 70 accelerator uh
that's a good combination for
when a person does not have adequate
coping skills for dealing with uh what
I'm gonna call maladaptive strategies
for managing negative affect when they
don't have good strategies for dealing
with their stress overwhelm exhaustion
depression loneliness
they might because their accelerator is
so sensitive and their brakes are like
their accelerator will be like well
let's just go do sex because sex feels
really good and much better than this
uncomfortable emotion I'm currently
experiencing and that's when a person is
at risk for like
having a higher risk relationship with
sexuality okay well let's and let's talk
on the other side rep both you and I are
high Jenna what was your number again on
the other side
so both high high
so what
maybe the best thing to talk about is
what if there's a mitch mismatch with
our partners because I'm like I know
that Christy would be like you know has
much more sensitive breaks than I've
established that I do so it's like
you know I let's just talk about that
like right I'll call it an extreme
mismatch but like what's the dynamic
there and then maybe we can interpolate
some of those like if you're in the
middle of you're the same but like it
seems like if you're both the same then
it's like okay this is
easier
but if you're Maybe
because so even if you have like the
same sensitivity of both of these parts
of your brain
um what they respond to might be really
different okay like one of you your
breaks responds very strongly negatively
when there is a risk of being caught for
example and the other one not so much
and you sort of want to incorporate that
kind of fantasy into your relationship
so it's less about the sensitivity of
the mechanism than what the mechanism
responds to gotcha but but let's talk
about if if you're when people really
sensitive breaks and not very sensitive
accelerator those are the folks who are
most likely to turn up in Sex Therapy
offices uh because like the slightest
little tap on the brakes can shut
everything down and what's the first
thing that happens in people's brains
when a slight little change hits their
brakes and they shut down
then they start going oh
darn it I hate when this happens every
single time when am I ever going to get
over this and does that self-criticism
does it activate the accelerator or does
it just hit the brakes more hit the
brakes more yeah so the you can get into
a spiral of like a sensitive break being
activated self-criticism and even
relationship criticism criticism from
your partner of like man why can't you
just ignore it why can't you just get
over it like it's not that big a deal
let's get back to it uh and like
everything just shuts down even more so
simply knowing this person has a
sensitive break a small distraction like
a noise in the hallway like kids
rattling around in the hallway uh
there's a sex researcher named Peggy
kleinplatz who interviewed an
80-something woman
who said that the most important sex
accessory was Vaseline you put it on the
doorknob
so if that tiny little thing is going to
distract you just know that that's true
know that that's just normal for this
person oh and don't freak out about it I
was like where is she inserting the
doorknob
yeah the children's tiny hands that yeah
that's uh but that is an interesting
interpretation of it I would not suggest
a doorknob but you know who am I right
you're tall enough to just bend over and
the doorknob's right I could probably
get one in my ass
um you know it make sure it has a flange
well the whole door is the flange
um
question because I feel like I have not
been thinking that viscerally about it
thanks for that image okay Emily
question for you because I obviously I
scored very high on this at 19. however
and I and I think that uh my wife would
be medium to
medium to high right and I think that
but she would also interpret me
sometimes as
to use the misnomer which we can talk
about as having a lower sex drive right
because she because we have a healthy
amount of sex she does initiate quite a
bit
um just for the record a healthy amount
of sex uh is any amount of sex that
feels right for you and your partner
that's why you're here thank you for
clarifying that
um for us we feel like it's a healthy
amount of sex that we're both satisfied
with but I think the thing that happens
often because we've established that I'm
thinking about sex quite a bit right and
I'm pretty much ready to go at any time
but she may not at times interpret me in
that way
uh because you know once once we are
engaged with one another
it's it and I I I want it to be
something that's not just a quick
obviously I can be satisfied and done
and you know very very quickly if I
wanted to if I didn't if I wasn't taking
her into account but I we don't ever we
I mean very rarely do we do that do we
have like what I would just call a
traditional quickie right we've had
conversations about this where she's
like well if that's if you want to do
that then we can up our frequency of
quickies but I just never feel right
about it so we do you know uh you know
we we go through the process and we and
then it becomes incredible but sometimes
there's a barrier to entry literally uh
of me wanting to engage in that way
which then is interpreted by her as a
you know me not wanting to have sex yeah
so it's like let's face it it's kind of
a project to get to the part where two
people are both in the mood and ready
can we talk about responsive and
spontaneous desire yes
because I feel like especially with uh
High
excitation score and uh medium to low
brakes score you're probably people who
experience spontaneous desire for sex
where it just sort of out of the blue uh
Erica Moen is the cartoonist who
illustrated come as you are and she
draws spontaneous desire as a lightning
bolt to the genital just Kaboom you know
I would like to have some sexy ones yeah
and you like you take your lightning
bolt to your partner and you're like uh
that's spontaneous desire
and your partner May or not may not be
there at that time but that is one of
the normal healthy ways to experience
desire another healthy normal way to
experience desire the research calls
responsive desire where instead of being
just a lightning bolt out of the blue
you like set up date night you get child
care you go to a bed and breakfast you
make plans you show up in the moment you
put your body in the bed you let your
skin touch your partner's skin and your
body and your brain go oh right
I really like this person I really like
this and then you get the Kaboom and
that's responsive desire where
spontaneous desire emerges in
anticipation of pleasure responsive
desire emerges in response to pleasure
yes
and what you've done is you've created a
context where your accelerator is
activated and your brakes all that stuff
that hits the brakes the body image
stuff and the stress and being stuck in
parent mode or work mode or whatever
else you do mode that is very far away
from erotic mode you can leave that all
behind you close the door and all those
other parts of your identity stay behind
that creates a context where your break
is freed up and your accelerator can go
and
we're we are busy we have a lot of other
things to do and for real generally
takes preparation and effort to create
that context where you don't have to be
in parent mode and distracted and in
householding mode and distracted and
work mode and distracted
so when it feels like a project to get
to the like I want to be really present
for my partner I want to be able to like
pay attention to the ways we're
connecting
it actually does take effort that is
normal you are doing it right yeah that
is the way you experience it and okay
I'll relate to this in a number of ways
first of all talking about like vacation
getaway sex is like it can be absolutely
amazing and there's like okay we set
aside this time we're looking forward to
it we're going away for two nights like
Child Care is taken care of this is
about us connecting we know like the
moment we get in the the room we're
gonna have at it and then we're gonna
have at it a few more times as many
times as we can this is like the focus
of our getaway right about how long you
have to wait front to front back to back
no how long do you have to wait in
between
um I mean we're not teenagers anymore
the perfect amount of time for us right
the healthy amount of time for us but
like well if you if if it was a
competition I just think answering that
question doesn't it's not any
competition
but I will say the the it is actually
truth around 18 your testosterone levels
Peak your sensitivity to it Peaks and so
your refractory period which is the
amount of time it takes you to get an
erection after the last time you
ejaculated that refractory period begins
to lengthen and then the reliability of
your erections gradually begins to go
down as you get into the sort of like
menopause age right so that's real so uh
yeah as As you move through your 40s and
into your 50s and hopefully you live a
long and erotic life deep into your 80s
and 90s your erections are being become
less reliable and that's fine erections
come and go and they are no more
important than you decide to make them
but back to the vacation sex for a
second right all right so it's like we
can have this amazing experience and
then it's like okay why can't we just
have that you know when we're back of
course the answer is the context of life
but one of the things that we'll do is
like sometimes we're like we'll be
having sex and we will have a
conversation about how great it is we'll
be like why did it why did it why did we
put this off this is the most amazing
thing that's happening right now and
then I start saying things like let's
let's commit right now to doing this
again tomorrow night and like I'm having
this like but you also do that with
things other than sex anytime any group
of you're in a group of people that are
having a good time you stop it makes
everyone acknowledge how good of a time
we're having and be like we have to plan
the next one right now I just think it's
like let's make our decision about the
next time we align based on this moment
like let's remember to factor this
moment in and let's weight it properly
this is this is one of the most amazing
experiences that we can have why did it
take the opportunity episode it's free
yeah
oh you did yeah okay I did my research
hey look I read your book we're all on
the same page here you didn't have to do
that but it's free and it isn't right
um so there's actually an Evidence base
to what you're doing which is the
research on savoring and there are parts
of what you're doing that actually do
increase the pleasure that you
experience in the moment and it shapes
your memory you're creating more of what
in inside out the Pixar cartoon they
call Core memories where you stop and
you talk to other people about how great
this is you notice the sensations that
are happening and how enjoyable they are
you compare it to like man those other
poor saps who don't get to experience
that I feel so sorry for them there's
all kinds of skills that you can imply
employ to make this moment you like
capture it in a photograph so that you
can return to it really easily and that
means that when you look back on your
life
you've just sort of accumulated Peak
moment after Peak moment after Peak
moment and your life feels both like it
has been more worth living and like it
has been longer
nice I love that idea heart a mental
photograph and like I have like a whole
pornographic drawer of movie in your
head yeah from my practice
yeah and the part that's not
evidence-based is we need to start
planning the next one now
yeah I write scheduled sex like you know
uh oh we do that Monday night there's
Lexi time there's lots of I we don't do
it every single week but we'll do it I
mean there's lots of times where it's
like
if if I'm like hey you want to go for it
and then there's like well we're not in
alignment or sometimes it's like I we
feel like it's been a while and we're
like I still feel I feel like [ __ ] right
now I'm not in the mood but
let's set a let's set a date that we can
look forward to uh two nights from now
whatever we do that all the time and I
feel like then we're each able to
prepare in our own way and also like the
expectations are aligned so it's not
like me walking up with a with a
lightning bolt and springing it on
that's what you call it
that's what Emily calls it
um
there's two answers really I recommend
scheduled sex all the time like I said
we are busy anything not on my calendar
doesn't happen
so I schedule sex because that's
especially when I'm traveling a lot on
the road
um and also just because you scheduled
it doesn't mean it's gonna happen there
have been times when I was on the road
traveling and I would get home and I
like have this little window of time
with my husband and it's scheduled and I
show up and I put my body in the bed and
I just like cry and fall asleep because
I'm so stressed and exhausted right yeah
yeah yes and fortunately I have I'm
married to one of the best human beings
on the face of the Earth and he's just
like no you're not I am really needs
that more
maybe there's like somewhere deep inside
him a part of him it's like we don't get
sex but he has never expressed that to
me and he's always really kind to
considerate and the fact that he is so
kind and considerate in that moment like
that builds a leg next time I'm gonna be
even more ready and enthusiastic because
he's so understanding and kind and
understanding yourself sexy loving it is
so hot the way he doesn't criticize or
judge me for being too tired to have sex
oh that's great well and you know
because we schedule
I I think and I speak I'm only I'm I'm
not a scheduler in general right so I
think there are people who think like me
and my wife is even less of a scheduler
than me would be like oh that takes some
of the spontaneity out of it but the
fact is absolutely is that you the
romance out of it you schedule we
schedule fun things all the time like
you say we are going to Disneyland on
Saturday
and it doesn't mean you don't enjoy
Disneyland because you have a ticket and
you've set aside the day right you know
it's like the only way I can enjoy
Disneyland is if we make a decision
right now to go and like I don't do we
have tickets I don't know let's figure
it out that would be in some ways I can
pull your pants down a horrible
experience right so I definitely don't
think scheduling is not sexy at all even
as someone who has difficulty scheduling
things including sex you should see
Chris and planner boy I I think that
might make her more horny than anything
I mean just a well appointed calendar
yes that was the joke in 30 Rock when
Liz Lemon wanted to get pregnant when
she was like if I schedule it and plan
him the way she could make like trying
to get pregnant sexy was like the fact
that she had to manage so many calendars
in order to get it done all right but
scheduling can backfire so suppose you
like set the date Saturday at three
o'clock you me in the red underwear and
one person like sees that date coming
and is like revving up to the time and
the other person is like oh
like it just feels like such an
obligation and I like I'm gonna show up
and they're gonna expect me to perform
in a certain way and just it's too much
pressure and it doesn't seem like it's
gonna work so scheduling does not work
for everyone
um but I do have a friend who
the couple was like very stressed they
were working on a political campaign and
it was approaching election time uh so
they were both just like
and they would never have sex if they
didn't schedule it yeah and it even got
to the point so they got they got these
dice you know like the silly dice that
you roll and it tells you to do
something
and it did not cause them to have more
sex but it caused them to spend an hour
and a half on Saturday morning playing
together and talking about intimacy and
that sustained an erotic connection
through this incredibly stressful season
of their lives and that's worthwhile too
even if you're not like having genital
contacts or doing something that counts
in your mind as having sex erotic play
together rein for play is the primary
friendship social behavior playing
together in that way
helps to sustain the connection even
when other things don't feel available
um so that's that's context let's get
back to the sex drive thing that you
mentioned at the top so sex drive is not
a thing
uh yeah so like I am not delusional I
know that sex drive is a very pithy easy
things to say but a sex drive means a
very specific thing biologically a drive
is uh like thirst and hunger there is an
uncomfortable internal Sensation that is
like a Wooga red flashing lights as it
pushes you out in the world to go solve
a problem and if you don't solve the
problem of getting adequate hydration or
adequate food or even yes adequate sleep
you have a sleep Drive what happens you
die you literally die yes that's a drive
sex is not one of those nobody ever died
because they couldn't get laid
nobody ever even got sick because they
couldn't get laid Yeah but
what sex is is a sexual incentive
motivation system and I know Sex Drive
is so much easier to say we're going to
keep saying sex drive but let's
understand in our hearts that we mean an
incentive motivation system instead of
an uncomfortable internal state that
pushes you to go fix the problem it is a
pleasurable internal state that pulls
you towards some attractive external
stimulus I always think of Bugs Bunny
being pulled on a hand of steam toward
an apple pie in a window
what's that oh I would like to go get
more of that sex is one of those and
it's important first of all to recognize
that no one is going to literally die
without sex people do literally die
of hunger for example which is why if
someone steals a loaf of bread to feed
their family we can feel like yeah I get
that but if someone
touches someone else's sexual body
because they hadn't gotten laid in a
really long time yeah yeah it is not
because they were starving it's because
they were really curious so that's
that's about the other person's sexual
thought yeah that's a great way of
clarifying exactly how you parse that
from a moral you know ethics standpoint
too right because an incentive
motivation system is just as natural
it's it can feel just as urgent like
we've all but curiosity is the ultimate
like analog to horniness you're just
like I just want to know more about that
I want to get closer I want to explore
it with every sense that I have yeah
that's curiosity and we all know also
that there are times in life when you
are more Curious in times in life when
you are less curious and that's not a
problem that's just the impact that
context has on which motivational
systems are most important right now wow
this makes me I I want to get your since
you know when you speak unlike when link
speaks or when I speak you say things
that are like informed and based on
extensive education which so while we've
got you here we're going to keep asking
you questions
um
and it's like strange to me because
we're the same age uh I think about like
what my life trajectory has been in
parallel to your like we were in college
at the same time and then y'all got
married and I stayed in school until I
was 29. well you know what it's paying
off
um for all of us it's paying off okay
asexuality right which has become
something that uh we've heard so much
more about that what you know when I was
a teenager I didn't even know it existed
right so one interpretation of it would
be like okay well is someone who
considers himself asexual are they just
someone who is just the they've got the
parking brake on on the inhibition scale
or is that not a helpful way to think
about that because that feels like it's
um like that is in fact factually
incorrect right that's what I thought
too the first time I was beginning to
learn about asexuality but there's
research on this about the sensitivity
of the accelerator and the breaks of
folks who identify as asexual which is
about one percent of the popular nation
in North America
and it turns out it is not that they
have a more sensitive accelerator
they're not that they have a more
sensitive break is that they have really
insensitive accelerators
it takes so much sex related stimuli to
get their accelerator going
um in fact uh there's an asexuality
there's an asexual sex educator named
Aubry Lancaster who uses the analogy of
Disneyland
yeah if you are married to a Disney fan
and they just love love going to
Disneyland and they can go to Disneyland
every day and you're like oh
like you guys you can go to Disneyland
now I really relate to it now I
completely understand because I'm I'm a
Disney sexual or whatever the the the
the proper term would be
because it matters to your partner
limited number of times you will go with
because it's fine and then you need a
long break before you go back again
because that's enough asexuality is but
I have been to the corn dog castle and I
will say that that can turn a trip to
Disneyland I can completely turn the day
around for me the corn dog I don't know
what that is it's just a place that
sells corn dogs
literally just corn dogs it's the best
part of Disneyland they're giant there's
wonderful I'm sure that fits in the
metaphor somewhere but I'm not exactly
sure yeah I don't know I could look like
a dildo yeah I don't know I'm working at
it I don't know what's happening but
asexuality is very varied there are sex
favorable Ace folks who are like I mean
okay like I don't feel the main thing
about asexuality is you don't feel
sexual attraction to people it's not
that your sexual response mechanism
doesn't function a lot of Ace folks
masturbate some don't uh it's that you
don't feel that attraction got it so
you're not like drawn to the person uh
but if your partner really wants you're
like yeah okay and it's fine uh other
folks are sex averse where the idea of
having sex is actively disgusting to
them then they don't want any part of it
so it's a very diverse Community my
favorite thing about Ace folks is that
they're entirely non-judgmental they're
very much about like let me explore what
feels right and good for me and they
often come up with great terms
demisexual gray sexual as well as
asexual
um qua sexual is my favorite term qua as
in the French what like uh I don't know
quasexual okay
um
if we go back to people who they're like
I don't know we talked about those
categories but if we go back to like all
right uh I'm in again I don't I
definitely don't want to use the term
normal I know that's not that's not what
I'm looking for here no you're just
sexual but if you like sex if you're if
you're more sexual you talked about a
bike analogy which I if I remember
correctly well remind me of what the
bike analogy is what I maybe you don't
remember either
anybody
nobody ever needs to ride a bike
yeah yeah but is it in the orgasm
chapter I think that's right I think it
what I took from it was
everybody does you don't have to ride a
bike but if you want to ride a bike you
can but you and if you want to really
enjoy it if that's a priority of yours
to ride a bike well you can learn how
you can enjoy it you can experience the
thrill of riding a bike if you want to
and if you're motivated enough if you're
motivated enough so it's to me there's
this thing about a Peloton that just a
stationary bike is that sure that too
change it but it's like that it's not oh
well everybody needs to ride a bike
or everybody needs to experience bike
riding in the same way but there is part
of the analogy that's like if if it's a
priority of yours to experience bike
riding
yeah then there's also a good amount of
work that goes into it you're investing
yourself to to to realize that enjoyment
that it takes learning it doesn't just
happen spontaneously
yeah like you have to the first time you
try the so in the context of for example
of learning how to have an orgasm for
the first time because you've never had
an orgasm a lot of people uh judge
themselves if they need to use a
vibrator for example or just that it's
been so long in their life and they
still haven't learned how to do this
thing that criticism and Judgment of
yourself it just hits the brakes and
makes it even more difficult to access
pleasure so you're just gonna not judge
and be like you know what this takes
practice I never got practice people
told me I wasn't allowed to ride a
bicycle and now I am learning from
scratch how to do this and so your hope
maybe you'll have a spotter maybe you'll
have training wheels and you'll go
through the process of gradually
learning and
when you learn to ride a bike you might
be like all right I did it and then
you're done or you might be like this is
amazing and I'm going to ride a century
now right
um to me just the investment in
my sex experience and like that that
aspect of me and Chrissy's relationship
is something that we we both learned
that we need to work at you know it's
like okay where is it where does that
fit in our priorities and let's you know
sometimes you gotta analyze and make
sure that your actions reflect that you
know so it's that's why I love coming
back to this for the second year in a
row as I think I said last week is that
like
acknowledging that it's work and then if
you're into it and it's a priority of
yours it you know it can be worth it I
think regardless of where you are and
you know what your particular situation
is I think one of the reasons that this
not only is are these conversations fun
and just you know lots of jumping off
points for comedy which is what we're
doing here but also
and more importantly is that I think
that information and communication are
all in my mind they're always good right
like when when you talk about the
subject of sex and we're getting the the
actual information from someone who uh
you know evidence that your
evidence-based approach to to this stuff
this is this is ultimately
it doesn't take away the sexiness to
make it sciency to make it scientific
right and well if you're in my brain it
makes it way more sense exactly and so
this being able to learn these things
and then what I hope comes from us
talking about these things is you know I
know us having this conversation will
lead to me and Jesse having a
conversation about the things that we
talked about right and having those
conversations that involve
fact-based evidence-based information
I've never seen engaging in that way
lead to a negative outcome it always
seems to move in the positive direction
when we give ourselves more we get more
equipment more information and we
continue talking about it that's what we
always talk about is that for us and our
friendship communication has been so
instrumental and that's people like well
how are you still working together after
all this time how are you still friends
since first grade it's like well you
gotta you there's ups and downs but you
have to keep talking about it and we
approach our marriages in the same way
um and and hopefully you can take the
information that we've gotten from uh
Emily today and then apply it to
whatever situation you are and there's
so much more information you've got this
book you've got your previous book where
can people get everything they need to
get from Dr Emily nagoski well reading
the books is always a great place to
start those come as you are and the come
as you are workbook if you find that
stress is really interfering with your
sexuality that's the reason I wrote
burnout with my identical twin sister
um because she literally ended up
hospitalized because of burnout stress
uh and uh I'm about to launch a come as
you are podcast from Pushkin industries
that launches in November nice and uh
you're working with that Malcolm
Gladwell
he shows up at every meeting he has some
great questions about orgasm okay cool
and I'm currently finishing a book about
sex in long-term relationships called
come together oh well hey there you go
that'll be out next summer yeah we're
ready for that one I want to see the
cover to that one it's actually
interesting the very first chapter is
called why have sex okay and you were
talking about like putting work into it
and like why why put the effort into
doing this frankly pretty silly
ridiculous sometimes very important
sometimes a little messy often very
silly thing that we humans do why do we
do it like talking to your partner like
why do we do this what what does it
bring to our relationship can't wait
Jenna what about you closing thoughts I
my kind of closing thoughts were just
how wonderful this book and just
allowing the conversations about sex can
be so helpful because I'm in my 30s now
and I read your book uh when I turned 30
like right around when I turned 30 and
it was one of those things I began and
reflecting on as a person who grew up
being like raised female and with that
all those connotations that come with it
and
how much reflecting I did on being High
um
uh High accelerator medium breaks and
realizing the coping mechanisms I used
in my early 20s
because of those things and how I wish I
had this kind of knowledge when I was in
my early 20s because there certainly was
Reckless and toxic behavior in my uh sex
life and in my like relationships in
general so like I just loved reading
this and be and I yeah I refer it to
anyone I can like anyone I can
especially like how lily was given the
book a link that you said and like I've
given the book to
um a girl that's kind of she's kind of
like a younger sister mentee kind of
thing family friend who's in college as
well and we've had those discussions it
just feels really nice to
have those people and be able to express
that in such a way I guess and I I just
I didn't have that I didn't have that
and I really like being able to talk
about it now and encouraging others to
talk about it yeah
that's that's my closing totally agree
I didn't have it either and that is why
I wrote the books I'm thrilled to hear
that thank you so much thanks so much
for your work doing great work Emily
thanks so much thank you for spend some
time talking with us and putting up with
our rabbit trip
total Delight
that was a splendid time yes it was uh
I'm excited about that podcast
now I'm gonna have to have two sex
podcasts that I listen to I'm gonna have
to listen to sex with Emily and the come
as you are podcast when that's that
comes out and again in that book about
uh long-term relationships come with me
is that what you said come together
because that's what we've got long-term
relationships
um next week we're going to be hearing
from you we're going to be
um so
let's see how that goes the sex talks
continue for one more episode use
hashtag your biscuits now to give us
responses or of course you can always
leave us a voicemail 188 earpod one
see you next week hey Rhett and Link
this is Amber from Austin Texas I just
finished listening to the episode how
much do we know about orgasms with Dr
Emily Moore I grew up in a very
religious Christian home and I was
sexually repressed which is something
that I'm still struggling to overcome to
this day I had never heard of Dr Emily
before and I learned some great things
from her on your podcast so thanks again
I love you all bye hey you guys thank
you so much for the episode with Dr
Emily Morse and I want to particularly
say thank you to Jenna for speaking so
openly about women's sex I'm a 49 year
old female and thought I was in a pretty
good group
but uh she did make some really great
points about the shame that you feel
about certain things and and the
pleasure that was one of the most
enlightening episodes I've ever heard
you guys do and this is too long a
message for you to put on the air I
listen to you all the time but September
actually means something I've learned a
lot hey Rhett and Link you know what I
just gotta say I just absolutely love
and adore you guys you guys have been
part of my life for 10 plus years now
and you are the greatest YouTubers
that I've ever known and I just love you
guys for being true down south awesome
dad awesome husbands great people and I
just love you guys and that's all
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]